now we're gonna analyze a more
complicated example of drag forces where
we have an object falling free in a
gravitational field with gravity we have
a resistive force and this is an object
in air and so our model will be for the
resistive force that it's going to be
proportional to the velocity squared now
to get its direction right opposing the
motion J hat so this will turn out to be
a more complicated analysis but first
again let's think about the units of our
coefficient data it has the units of
force divided by velocity squared so we
write the units of force kilogram meters
per second squared and the units of
velocity squared meter squared per
second squared and so we see that we
have units of kilogram per meter for our
coefficient beta now we'll apply as
usual Newton's second law F equals MA to
get our equation of motion we're looking
at the J direction and our forces are
gravity minus the velocity squared
resistive drag force and that's equal to
the derivative of the velocity DV DT in
this example it's a one-dimensional
motion so I'm dropping any mention of
our y-direction for simplicity now we
can rewrite this equation as DV DT let's
divide through by M is G minus beta over
m V squared and this is a linear it's a
first order differential equation DV DT
it's a nonlinear equation because the
velocity term appears here is a square
and there's a constant term but we can
still apply our technique of separation
of variables and so will we write this
equation as DV DT will separate out the
DVS and the T's so we have DV times G
minus beta over MV squared is equal to
DT now I'm going to do two
just to clean this up for algebra a
little bit later I'm gonna multiply both
sides by a minus sign and I'm going to
pull the G out so I have one minus beta
over mg b squared and on the other side
I have minus DT and now I can get this
equation in the form that I'd like to
integrate which is minus DV times 1
minus beta over mg B squared equals
minus G DT now the trouble here is this
integral is a little bit complicated so
I'd like to make a change of variables
and my change of variables will be U
equals the square root of beta mg times
V and that implies that D U is data mg
DV and the limits if we start our object
at rest so if u not equal 0 then because
V naught equals 0 that's our first limit
now we have to be a little bit careful
because if we drop this object at rest
initially it will be moving very slowly
and so our resistive model it doesn't
actually apply however we're going to
neglect that effect even though if we
were to do a more complicated analysis
we would have to change our model as the
object is falling so it will be a
multi-stage motion first at the
beginning with our only velocity
dependent resistant and then as it gets
some initial speed and it's going faster
we change our model that's why the
actual problem can be quite complicated
but we're just trying to keep things
simple here and then U at T is square
root of beta mg V of T and then with
this change of variables my integration
remember I have a DV so I have to
multiply the left side by mg over beta
and I'm integrating with the minus sign
do you times 1 minus u squared from 0 to
this final value U of T and over here
I'm just integrating minus G DT now
again for simplicity I'm going to bring
this term the beta over mg over to the
other side so I'll use the magic of our
light board by just erasing that and
bringing it to the other side which
makes my life a little easier and now
you this integral can be done by the
method of integration by parts it's a
nice problem in calculus and you can
verify for yourself that the result is
1/2 natural log of 1 plus u over 1 minus
u evaluated at our limits and over here
I have minus G square root of beta over
mg now once again for a little bit of
simplicity I'm going to bring the two
over to the other side and now I
evaluate my limits now recall that when
you have a minus log we're flipping
because log of B over a equals minus log
over a B so when I put out my limits in
I have natural log of now remember what
are our limits we have 1 I'm flipping
minus U is beta mg times V of T and I
have the 1 plus beta mg B of T
and that's equal to minus 2g square root
of beta mg now again we'll use the fact
that not that e to the log of X is X and
so if i exponentiate both sides I end up
with 1 minus square root of beta mg V of
T over 1 plus square root of beta mg V
of T is equal to exponential minus 2 G
beta M G times T okay now this is a
little bit of algebra I want to solve
for V of T if I bring this side over to
there I'll just do that to make the
first step a little simpler to see so we
have 1 minus square root of beta mg V of
T equals 1 plus square root of beta over
mg
V of T times e to the minus this factor
2 G square root of beta mg T no this is
a lot of stuff to carry around I'd like
to introduce a constant here tau which
I'm going to define to be square root of
Mg beta 1 over 2g and so this whole term
is going to just be e to the minus tau
it's a nice example for you to work out
that the units of tau are the units of
seconds and that's a little exercise to
work out now I just have to collect my
terms and what I'll do is I'll collect
the T terms on the right and the terms
that don't have bt on the left so I have
1 minus e to the minus T over tau on the
left is equal to 1 plus e to the minus T
over tau on the right times
betta mg B of T and so I get my solution
V of T equals the square root of mg over
beta times 1 minus e to the minus T over
tau over 1 plus e to the minus T over
tau well it's not a simple solution at
all but let's examine when you have a
case like this again it would be nice
exercise to graph this out but right now
we're going to consider the limit as T
goes to infinity and remember that e
minus T over T goes to 0 when T goes to
infinity so we just have 1 over 1 and
what we get as T goes to infinity is the
quantity mg over beta and this is what
we call the terminal velocity now what
does terminal velocity mean well when
object is falling and there's a
resistive force as the object falls
faster and faster the resistive force
gets greater and greater until if we go
back to Newton's second law and look at
it as the V gets faster and faster
eventually these two terms are equal and
when these two terms are equal that's
the statement that the right-hand side
has to be 0 so what we mean by terminal
velocity is it's the velocity is no
longer changing in time and then we can
immediately check our work by going to
Newton's second law and see what that
case is if we set this quantity equal to
0 in other words when we set mg minus
beta V squared terminal equal to 0 we
can solve for V terminal and we get
square root of Mg divided by beta and
that agrees with our lengthy calculation
so we think we're on the right track
you